welcome to CBS this morning at the
Oscars the 92nd Academy Awards were all
about historic moments in tackling the
controversy the South Korean thriller
parasite was a big upset becoming the
first non-english language film to win
the Oscar for Best Picture Wow
it also scooped up three other awards in
the night including Best Director it was
a surprising ending after all for acting
frontrunners won their statues as
expected hollywood's big night was also
punctuated by politics Entertainment
Tonight host Kevin Frazier was there and
joins us from the et set in LA Kevin
were the stars aligned in their message
last night oh they were Anthony good
morning and you know if there was a
theme to the night it was about
diversity and inclusion or the lack
thereof the Academy had taken some
criticism this year about a lack of
minority and female nominees so as it
looked at Hollywood's best it also
seemed to be taking a hard look at
itself the Academy Awards began with a
call for diversity from singer Janelle
Monae backed by African American dancers
including some dressed as characters
from snubbed films
it's an issue highlighted by Steve
Martin and Chris Rock as well back in
1929 there were no black acting nominees
no and now in 2020 we got one that
nominee is Cynthia Revo all women are
superheroes the inclusion of women also
took center stage actress Natalie
Portman wore a cape embroidered with the
names of female directors many felt were
overlooked among the all-male nominees
including hustlers Lorene scoff aria and
the farewells Lulu Wong thank you all
for this gift it was a sentiment echoed
by Laura Dern winner of Best Supporting
Actress for marriage story backstage she
gave a shout-out to the overlooked
director of Little Women
if I could give her - Greta Gerwig I
would do it right now Brad Pitt Brad
Pitt won Best Supporting Actor who once
upon a time in Hollywood he got
political onstage alluding to president
Trump's new trial it told me I only have
45 seconds up here which is 45 seconds
more than the Senate gave John Bolton
this week we're talking about the fight
against injustice and Joaquin Phoenix
who won best actor for Joker spoken
defense of all those who were oppressed
fighting back tears as he quoted his
late brother after River Phoenix he said
run to the rescue with love and peace
will follow thank you parasite but
history is likely to remember last
night's Oscars as the first time a non
english-language film took the top
honors parasite won four awards
including Best Picture and Best Director
for bong joon-ho say history but I never
intended that we just made a movie now
parasites other two Oscars were major
ones as well Best Original Screenplay it
is a great story and Best International
feature film and as many expected Renee
Zellweger won Best Actress for her
portrayal of Judy Garland and Judy you
will hear what she had to say
backstage coming up in our next hour
gale well Kevin let's talk about Paris
that for just a second number one I saw
the movie and I was a little hesitant
because I really don't like looking at
movies with subtitles but it was so good
that you forget that you're reading yes
don't you think what you're reading will
be stuck with me as much as that that
this year but I'm wondering about the
reaction they got in the room because it
seemed they got a lot of love from that
audience and I was so glad to see that a
lot of people loved the movie because a
lot of people in the Academy saw the
movie you know this movie has grossed a
little over 30 million dollars which is
a drop in the bucket when you compare it
to movies like the Joker or even 1917
but it is a great story and this story
will be adapted by HBO to an
americanized so you will see it very
very soon in a venue where you don't
have to read sometimes any Americans of
Nazi but it was so good back at 8 so
we'll look forward to talking in
conversation